whenever I'm asked to portray the
journey of a character that goes way
beyond my life experience which is often
the first place I visit is of course for
guidance and inspiration documentary
film in preparation for Schindler's List
for example a film about people and
events and an entire mentality that is
far outside anything of our current
experience today I watched many hours of
brave extraordinary and horrifying
documentary footage when we made
Schindler's List
oh sorry when we made shutter island'
for Martin Scorsese as painstaking and
detailed or into director as you could
ever wish to meet we screamed Fredrik
Wiseman's titty cart for ease anyone who
sees that film will understand its value
immediately in capturing the entire
visceral sense the place in this case a
hospital for the criminally insane it
goes without saying that Wiseman's
documentaries offer information pure
information and powerful emotional
moments to their audiences but speaking
as a fellow craftsman his gift to me has
been extraordinary
he and his fellow documentarians have
given me a confident knowledge that I
can present gesture a certain turning
point in the narrative as true even if
I've never experienced it myself because
I've seen it all mr. Weisman scream I
would urge every actor in this room and
outside this room to watch every single
one of mr. Weissman's films because
therein lies the truth